à
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être avec nous émission de ce
soir je vais soulever et tu vas devoir
me dire quel objet tués dans en train de
tripoter tu mettras t'es d'min des deux
côtés comme ça à quoi tu penses c'est
jean michel maire dont ckoi net
salesches saleix ce qui bat gens sachent
c'est quelqu'un de connu maintenant
retour à son mmorpg
on peut les maintenant au tour de sophie
siouplaît le retour assez pierre-jean
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cinquante mille albums je vous annonce
ce soir que vous êtes disque d'or
on oublie que le disent que leur l'a
vécu un petit souci avec le disque d'or
c'est je crois que certains ont pété le
dise non
[Applaudissements]
il ya passé une demi-heure dans les wc
d'un restaurant chinois un des serveurs
a dit qui a déféqué autant dans les
toilettes s'est inventé moi c'est que
j'ai deux témoins il y avait bien sûr le
m j'avais moi même mais ma femme et elle
est partie aux toilettes et elle a
disparu très très longtemps mais
vraiment très très haute on s'est
inquiété ans et demi oui kelly il ya un
monsieur qui est ronde et des toilettes
qui dit qu'il ya eu
m ramos toilettes mais un drame
ils ont fermé les toilettes narguer la
police
le rendu est tout a rendu les poneys
[Musique]
c'est rien ça il est vrai il au 21
octobre les ventes de ses produits à
l'échelle dans tout va bien sûr tout va
bien il est à dire quand ça va
franchement c'est pas le meilleur moment
à las vegas mais ça restera mais jusqu'à
la fin de mes jouets comme vous êtes
il a été enfermé en dehors de sa chance
et pourtant elle est obligée de
traverser tout le tel un petit slip
aller chercher les clés l'accueil est
souple et bonnes femmes tout le monde le
regarde dépasser mais comme un ovni
j'ai adoré leur regard et s'est marié 40
en annonçant le meilleur moment de ta
vie
déjà marié alors oui quand il a fait sa
demande en mariage il a mis sa ou dans
de l'herbe lama gilad vous avez fait
votre demande
je me souviens plus exactement je crois
que je classique je pense avoir été
acheté une bague
il n'est pas la bonne taille qu'on a du
ai'a pour l'élargir wave classic une
bague je crois d'accord normal france ne
sais quoi avec ma voix normale
d'habitude à à un corbeau enfin de ligue
le corbeau qui rentre chez lui c'est
quoi non mais je vous jure
quand je fais le corps mois décor mots
viennent d'assez longues heures pour toi
ouais un honneur un honneur on est tous
des winners
one two three
mais c'est par des séries louis borloo
maire a écouté
[Rires]
[Musique]
pagano là
m
[Applaudissements]
oh que oui à panneaux ce coup là
qui se cache derrière le rideau blaquart
[Applaudissements]
sa maman star
alors vous dites quoi comme renault ou
même pourquoi moi je dirais un vu qu'on
connaît bien mais sopron froid qui sévit
aussi avec la coupe à la rousseau way
attendu chez lui un senior la famille
c'est que c'est ça ouais au bras on va
regarder tout de suite qu'ils
s'attaquent ce sera avec nous ouvrez
[Applaudissements]
c'est pourquoi
on prend 4
[Applaudissements]
à
à l aller